President Trump appears to be standing
firm on his plan to withdraw US troops
from Syria now this comes after a deadly
attack targeting Americans there Isis
says this morning it carried out the
suicide bombing that killed four
Americans and at least twelve others
yesterday the attack shows how the
terror group still has clout in spite of
US claims it has defeated Isis a White
House statement says our deepest
sympathies and love go out to the
families of the brave American heroes
David Martin is at the Pentagon where
the president will make a scheduled
visit later today David good morning
good morning the Syrian city of man beds
used to be a success story
a town liberated from Isis returning to
a semblance of normal life but now it is
the scene of the single worst loss of
American life since US troops went in
this area more than three years ago the
suicide bomber can be seen on a security
camera as he walked down a crowded
sidewalk and blew himself up in front of
a restaurant where Americans patrolling
the city had stopped to eat four of them
were killed two soldiers a civilian and
a contractor and another three
servicemen wounded along with a dozen or
more Syrians
the attack drew an instant reaction from
Senator Lindsey Graham not what hoped
the president would look long and hard
before he's headed in Syria the bomber
had picked the right restaurant at the
right time on the right day suggesting
Isis had been tracking the movements of
American patrols and that US troops had
fallen into a pattern Isis could predict
Graham himself has been damaged and
thinks he ate at the same restaurant
Isis claims responsibility if true that
shows that they're not defeated and
they're been involved we have won
against Isis we've beaten them and we've
beaten them badly we've just weeks ago
President Trump announced he was
withdrawing all US troops from Syria and
there is no sign the attack has changed
his mind
hours after it happened vice president
pence restated the president's intention
to get out we are bringing our troops
home the Caliphate has crumbled Jane
Cara Fano is a foreign policy expert
with a conservative Heritage Foundation
what would be tragic as if the United
States left a vacuum like we did when we
pulled out of Iraq that created a space
for a group like Isis to rebuild a
Caliphate it's been more than 24 hours
since the attack and President Trump has
not yet said anything about it that
could change in a moment with a tweet or
later today when he comes to the
Pentagon to give a speech be honor all
right David thank you